我的态度就这样，
我对于赌徒我从来不会给第二次机会，
这是我直播间几乎一以贯之的，
就是我如果跟一个赌徒去共同生活，
共同生育孩子，
我明知他是赌徒，
我还继续跟他生活在一起，
那我赌的比他还大，
我也是个赌徒，
你比他赌的还大，
我是一个县城里面事业单位上班的，
一个月工资大概4000左右吧，
我们家那个他是外地，
跟我不在同一个地方上班，
他是上20天休10天这种的，
她一个月大概一万，
我现在孩子是两岁了，
平时呢，
就是我妈还有我婆婆相护这种看孩子什么的，
她放假的10天左右吧，
除了就是路上的行程，
8天左右到家，
但是他总是就是待一两天吧，
他就想走，
因为我们在小县里面是租房子住，
然后我们市里面有房，
他就是老是想回市里面，
他就一个人走了就好几次这种的，
就是出去和朋友玩呀，
也有可能这种，
因为他平时倒是上班没时间，
再一个就是我们结婚前吧，
我就知道他有那个贷款，
估计有10W左右吧，
但是因为他当时说是他就是大手大脚的，
确实他说是一直没攒出钱，
花钱什么的呀，
他就不借呀什么的，
后来就欠下这些钱，
当时也说了，
说结婚了肯定就不一样了，
然后他就说这种的，
后来结婚了之后，
我想着如果要是好好传的有10W，
其实。
也不算多，
现在就是出了这个事情，
他就说让我给他贷款，
然后我就没同意，
因为他说是我的那个贷款的，
那个利率低嘛，
就好贷一些，
然后我说那你不管是什么原因，
高呀什么的，
你就自己贷吧，
因为这些都是你自己的原因造成的，
后来他就自己应该带了30个，
反正他也没有拿回家多少，
他也没跟我说，
就是反正是30个，
现在也没有，
他就是有时候一个月给我3000~5000，
有时候就没有了，
就是他也没有自己节省的这种情况，
他就是什么也不做，
就是自己该吃吃该该喝喝，
该玩玩，
他也不操心，
他这30个怎么还，
以后我就是有点担心，
反正他平时也不顾家什么的，
我觉得吧，
20天过的其实辛苦的，
我觉得还挺开心的，
他就回来吧，
我就不行，
就是这种的，
这几天我俩就因为就是小事呀，
争吵这种的，
我就不知道该怎么办，
那你最终你是没有给他贷款呢，
还是已经给他贷了30万，
如果没有给他贷是他自己贷的，
没有给他贷就对了，
那你现在想要问我啥问题呀，
我想过离，
但是我觉得到了那个离的地步了嘛，
因为孩子还小两岁，
这小县城里面要是离的就是那种钻言三语的，
我也不想这种，
就是你要不理他该怎么办，
就是我也不知道不离该怎么办，
因为他又打人赔7万，
贷款又30万，
你见着他工资了吗？
虽然说他的工资1万块钱你见着了吗？
工资花到家里头了吗？
你和孩子花他的。
钱了吗？
对，
就是这个钱，
他虽然挣的就是比我多，
但是他实际在家里面，
他从来没有说是按时给我3K啊5K啊，
就是偶尔给过5K这种的，
所谓的风言风语，
这事儿的话，
其实我感觉啊，
没有我和孩子身体健康有饭吃，
不欠债这个事情来的重要，
他又赌又打人，
又欠这么多债，
什么时候才是个头啊，
当他拿孩子绑架你，
给你下跪，
你什么时候可能就心软了，
又给他贷款了，
对，
我就是考虑到就是贷款三年，
估计到时候他这个钱怎么办？
就是他从来来也不考虑这些，
他自己该吃吃该喝喝，
该玩玩，
他出去玩就是这个，
你自己琢磨啊，
你是要跟着一个无底洞天天给他填窟窿，
哎，
这么没有盼头的过日子，
还是说自己尽早的撤离出来，
跟孩子踏踏实实过日子，
你自己去考虑啊，
就是我如果要是那个什么的话，
就是他的这些贷款跟我有关系，
最好是在协议里面白纸黑字的写清楚，
他的这些贷款他是用来干嘛的，
没有用到家庭生活当中，
是他的个人债务，
跟你没有关系，
离婚协议里面这么写就可以下白纸黑字写清楚啊，
主要是因为孩子太小，
我不想，
就是想忍一忍，
反正他回来也没几天，
就是说孩子太小，
总得有个爸爸这种，
那你再考虑考虑吧，
反正我的态度就这样，
我对于图我从来不会给第二次机会，
这是我直播间几乎一惯。
知道，
就是我如果跟一个赌徒去共同生活，
共同生育孩子，
我明知他是赌徒，
我还继续跟他生活在一起，
那我赌的比他还大，
我也是个赌徒，
你比他赌的还大，
反正就是写天数，
这些跟我没关系也行，
是是的，
没错啊，
孩子的抚养权的话，
因为我没有房子嘛，
他跟我的话，
会不会那个什么，
如果真的要是这样的话，
孩子抚养权你自己能挣钱养活自己和孩子嘛，
工作稳定也不能照顾孩子的，
是因为他那头他的工作有特殊性，
他是没法照顾孩子的呀，
对他没法照顾，
所以你是有优势的呀。
嗯，
懂，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜啊，
我真的跟所有全天下的女孩子讲，
如果你谈的对象是个赌徒，
如果你找的老公是个赌徒，
如果你愿意跟她继续过下去，
那么你也是赌徒，
你比她赌的还大，
你赌的是你和你孩子的未来，
你赌的是你的人生，
她只是赌钱，
记得点赞关注哦。